foreign
[Silence]
our discussion
and our reading and our journey
through the books
authored by the late and esteemed
scholar of islam
is one of those rare individuals
in the history of islam
there are many many many scholars
throughout the history of islam
millions the centuries
but there are only a few
and when i say a few with respect to
those millions
that are absolutely exceptional
in that they have perfected
not just learned not just studied but
perfected and specialized
in more than one science of islam
many people know about
the greater imams of phil
for instance a certain
science so for example imam malik
we all know illinois the great imam
one of the four imams most people don't
know that he was
more profound and
more respected and esteemed
in the science of hadith than he was
in the science of phil a lot of people
don't know that about him
a lot of people don't know that about
al-imam shafiri as well
and that al-imam is
considered one of the
references of the arabic language
what does that mean meaning that if we
wish to see
if a certain word or a certain clause or
a certain type of
sentence structure is something that is
acceptable
in the arabic language if al-imam is
narrated to have said it
it is because he was
especially gifted in the science of
grammar and the arabic language and a
profound poet
as well and so on and so forth
now
he specialized in most
sciences of islam
the science of grammar the science of
linguistics
the science of hadith and that is
evident
in his book
his summarization of surah
right in the science of
which is evident in zadil ma'ad and
other works of his
he specialized in the science of
us
and that is evident in his book
he specialized in the science of tafsir
which is very evident in his book
mederegis
b he specialized
in most of the sciences of islam
if not all of them that is a great feat
a person could spend his entire life
just reaching
one of those specialties
right it was said by some of the
earlier self earlier scholars of hadith
that the sciences of hadith are 100
and each one of them a man could spend
his life
perfecting so
it is a very rare kind of person
to write a book this and this is
why we spend so much time
on the works of abnor this is why ibn
al-qayyam is so well respected
in all circles or
all relevant circles because
of his high status
in the sciences of islam rahimahullah
his words are gold and you can
almost root back every single sentence
he makes
to a verse of the quran or a narration
of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and this is what
al-fudailah
rahimahullah said
[Silence]
whoever takes the revelation of allah
and makes it dominant
over himself he will speak with wisdom
and whoever takes the revelations of
allah
and whoever takes his own opinions
and makes those dominant over himself
he will speak with innovation
now so we were continuing in
how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would bury the dead
this is where we have reached we will
read a passage
and we will explain it and we will
continue on in this way
if mid-stream you find that i add more
arabic than
english or more english than arabic this
is because the crowd in front of me has
changed
right so don't be frustrated by that
inshaallah
we're trying to disseminate this
knowledge to everyone as much as
possible
yahoo
he said and it is of his sunnah
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would waste no time in
preparing the deceased
for his burial and his meeting with
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
so he would hasten the burial
and there are narrations in which the
prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam outright commanded
that we hasten our
taking thee deceased to his grave
that we not waste any time in doing so
now what does that mean does that mean
that we should take this literally
or should we take this
or that we should take this
how literally should we take this
basically
some people understand that if you
carry the casket you should jog and you
should run with it
now that is not what is intended by the
narration
it's not intended by the narration like
in our time
that if we put the
coffin or the deceased into the hearse
that the hearst
take off and leave everybody in the
procession behind
or that we drive maniacs down the
street
trying to literally speed
the process that's not what is intended
what's intended is that we waste no
time unnecessarily right
that he doesn't sit or she doesn't sit
in a freezer for three days
while we get around to it or that the
as some of the mushrikeen used to do
would leave the body for a day or two in
the house
right and burn incense and oils and
remove all mirrors because they used to
fear that the
soul would be trapped inside of these
mirrors
so on and so forth different things of
jehelia
that they would do or that we leave the
body sitting around
for two or three days so that everybody
can come and see
the body this is something that we have
here in america it's called
viewing right so we have usually two or
three days of viewing
so we have the funeral home open and
the guy is sitting out in the
casket and everybody comes and looks at
the person
all of this is of innovation and of the
ways of jehelia
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
commanded
haste in preparation of the body
not speed
per se but haste in not wasting any
time a question comes into
comes to mind a lot especially in a
place america
so a lot of people here in america they
have family
outside of the country right
they have children outside of the
country they have parents or
relatives or whatever it is
should we delay the burial until the
family members come from overseas or not
this is the question and the answer
is we should not delay the burial
until anyone comes from overseas
the person has a right to be buried as
soon as he passes away
and the presence or absence of his
family members has no bearing on the
deceased rather what has a bearing on
the deceased is
failing to follow the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
in giving him his rights to be buried
with haste
this is incorrect sometimes they'll
leave the body for a day or two or three
while all of the family gets together
and decide on a date
this is haram right allah said in the
quran
[Silence]
so it's important for us to understand
that
the and i know that a lot of people
aren't going to listen to this advice
because let's face it people's
customs a lot of times override
what we know of the sunnah right so a
person passes away and i say well i'm
his brother or i'm his father
i'm a son or i'm i need to be there for
his burial
yes if you can get there in time within
a day
a reasonable amount of time sure that's
that's wonderful that's great that's
fine
otherwise you cannot delay the burial of
your muslim brother
of a muslim simply because you want to
be present
this is not conscionable
right and this is not acceptable it's
against the sun of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
many of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's companions
many of them and of them were his family
members
who passed away in other lands and he
never traveled to the
to the burial he stayed in medina made
dua for them
passed away and one of the was martyred
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam did
not travel to bury him
he allowed him to be buried in a proper
amount of time
wherever he was killed right
for a person to travel to be
in a particular funeral this is not
something that is necessary
right this is not something that is
necessary
and if it entails delaying the burial of
a muslim then it is not permissible
this is unacceptable when we say a
person should be
hastened his burial should be hastened
let's speak about
our time today here in america
in america we have paperwork we have
autopsies we have all kinds of things
right
what we're speaking about is as soon as
possible
the person is to be buried person passes
away
they have to be released by the hospital
let's say
or the coroner feels that the death is
suspicious
and so an autopsy has been has been
recommended or been commanded an ops
an autopsy takes place as soon as this
autopsy or as soon as the release papers
have happened or as soon as all of that
is
is finished we immediately begin
the preparation of the body and so
we begin the preparation of the body
daytime or night time
whenever it is and there are instances
when some of the companions were buried
at night
now but this is not
necessary this
may be for some reason right
so for example
was buried at night why was he buried at
night
he was buried at night because there
were many people who
a group of people who had began to
almost worship him they revered him too
much
and so it was paramount that his grave
be
unmarked and unidentifiable to this
group
lest it become and be turned into a
shrine
where other than allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is worshiped
so the people of that time they buried
alibi in secret in the night time
that's a reason to bury at night but
usually
burials will take place in the daytime
if a person dies and we prepare him at
night
should we wait until the next day to
bury him
in the daytime the answer is yes why
because more people will be present to
make salah upon the person
correct and this is of benefit and of
consequence
to the deceased so for example
people pass away here all the time they
pass away at night
they're released at night but we always
make salah usually
usually sometimes later but usually a
bull here
at the masjid here at this masjid a
person may say why why don't you pray it
10 o'clock or nine o'clock
as soon as the body is ready as soon as
the gravedigger is ready
as soon as the funeral
the as soon as the as soon as the
graveyard is ready
we would say because that delay of a few
hours
is inconsequential and it will
be of benefit to the person who has
passed away
right because for instance we have a
huge crowd that prays with us
most likely after we're finished most
people will head outside
or head to the middle hall and pray
solatill
and the more people we have praying
solaitel geneza
the more it will be beneficial to the
person who has passed away
that is a cause to delay a couple of
hours there's no problem with that
that is fine if we have a choice between
burying a person at nine o'clock with
only ten people to make salah
or burying a person at one o'clock with
a hundred and fifty people to make salia
we will choose one o'clock right this is
of al-hikma
and this is of weighing the good
and evil and weighing thee
where do we get this from well the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
in the narration
[Silence]
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
has mentioned
that no individual will pass away
and a hundred and in another wording 40
individuals will pray over this person's
body
after his death except that allah will
grant
them intercession on his behalf
what does that mean intercession and we
intercede on behalf of
this person that allah forgive him so
allah will accept this intercession
why the discrepancy in numbers why in
one narration he says a hundred and in
another wording he says 40
because it depends on the equality of
the people making salah
the quality of the people the quality of
their religion
their religiosity some
communities are strong in their islam
strong in their knowledge
far from sheikh far from associating
partners from allah
close to the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
less of them is more and some
communities are weaker
and further from the sunnah and less
knowledgeable
and amongst them is more sinfulness
and so there is more necessary for this
intercession
to be acceptable
when we speak about hastening the
process
of burial we're not talking about
running with the casket
we're not talking about speeding down
the highway at 70 miles an hour
we're talking about preparing
within reason the body
for burial and placing the person in his
grave
as soon as reasonably possible
we mentioned that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
would often bathe or
have bathed the deceased
and would use kefur
and he would also use a siddhir
he would use siddhir which is a type of
tree that would grow in the desert at
that time
he would take the leaves of siddhar and
he would crush them up and he would put
them
in the water right mix them in the water
and then he would bathe the body the
bathing of the body would be three times
or five times or seven
times or as many times as necessary to
get the body to be
bathed and purified of
obvious dirt or
obvious you know
to make the body obviously clean
now why would he use siddhir we have to
look at this
he would use siddhir as was used with
his daughter zainab
and bukhari a muslim because
it has cleaning properties to it
right it has cleaning properties to it
[Silence]
foreign
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would use siddhar
is a type of tree because of its
cleaning properties
we don't have to import this particular
lotus plant now
we don't have to grow it here we don't
have to have it
in abundance in our funeral homes in
order to
wash bodies with it we can use
the soap that's available for us today
why because the point of a siddir is its
cleaning properties
and we have that in modern soap right
just like
a siweck right what's the point of a
siwak
does it have to be the root of a rock
tree
in order for us to achieve the sunnah
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
the answer is no what's the point of a
siwac
what's the point of it that's a real
question what's the point of it
clean your teeth so if you clean your
teeth with a rag or if you clean your
teeth with a toothbrush
or if you clean your teeth with colgate
or if you clean your teeth with arm and
hammer
you have completed the sunnah of the
prophet
you have done the same thing that the
prophet salallahu
salem did right
we don't have to use that exact same
instrument because we're looking for
the reason that he used that instrument
not necessarily the instrument
itself do we understand that
let's say for example we have a screw
that we need to unscrew right
does it matter the type of screwdriver
that i use
whether it's a craftsman or whether it's
a
any of these different types of of
hardware or tool shop or
dewalt or doesn't matter right that's
that
that that is inconsequential what
matters to us is that the screw come out
correct if the screw comes out we've
we've done exactly what we were what we
were looking for
now i don't want anybody to take what
i'm saying and say oh the shirt said
don't use siweck
i'm not saying that you see work
but you don't have to go to hajj and get
a big bundle of it this big
and that's the only thing you use
otherwise i'm not doing the sunnah
right that's that's what i'm talking
about
right that's what we do
we go overseas we look for
a siddha when i get bathed i need to be
bathed in a siddhar and my shroud has to
be made from the same materials shrouds
used to be made in the time
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and all of these things
this is focusing on
the tool rather than focusing on
the task correct so let's say for
example if i point
at something is my pointing
is the point of it my finger or what i'm
pointing at
obviously what i'm pointing at my finger
is merely a
it's a means to an end right
for example the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said if a dog
drinks out of your cup or
eats off of a plate of yours
in order to purify it you must wash it
how many times seven times
one of those seven times being with
with dirt correct we know this narration
this narration is
everyone is aware of it meshi
so what if instead of using dirt i use
palm olive dish soap does that take the
place or not
the answer is yes it takes the place in
the correct opinion
of the scholars of islam it takes the
place of
dirt was palmolive dish soap available
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
no it was not now it is right
let me give another example
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
let's say there was water that was
impure
it had impurities in it right
how would i make that water pure
who knows huh
no add more water
right so for example
if i have a pot and a and it
and let's say a rat or something died in
it
okay how do i salvage that water in the
time of the prophet salallahu
i remove as much impurity as i can
and i add more water to where
i can no longer taste or smell or
see a difference
right as the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
[Silence]
he said water is pure as long as its
taste
smell or color has not changed
right and you know this kind of reminds
me i'll get off topic a little bit
it reminds me of one of the major
scholars of hadith
he
[Silence]
foreign
likewise the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would use
kafran kafur
he would use kaphron in the final
washing of the body
why would he use camphor kaphron
some sometimes it's referred to as
camphor it has a very distinct smell
[Silence]
or camphur is used often in vick's
rub
that smell that distinct potent
smell of vicks rub that is camphor
the prophet sallallahu alaihi often use
that in the final washing of the body
right why would he use that
the scholars mention because its smell
is potent
and it usually wards off bugs
and insects from the body
for an amount of time
[Silence]
so he would use camphor in the final one
should we use camphor yes if it is
available we should use it
and we should use it as the prophet
salallahu sallam did
likewise
[Silence]
a
when he would prepare a body for
burial he would put the perfume in the
person's
body in the person's beard
hair if it is a female he would have the
hair braided
zainab
he was
[Silence]
it is also the sun of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that if a woman has long hair that her
hair be braided
when she passes away in preparation for
her burial
rash
[Silence]
foreign